today we're checking out the brand new
Microsoft Pro X this thing is incredible
I got a chance to check it out while I
was in New York at their press event but
today we have it in hand and we're gonna
unbox and take a look I guess I open it
now here we go
I don't love that they give us a little
illustration here of us PC USB C power
plug smile so this thing is really light
it's about 12.7 pounds and it's a seven
two point three millimeters thin but I'd
love a barrel at the surface is there's
a two in one so I can use it as a tablet
I can also use it more in traditional
sentence as a laptop doesn't smell like
anything I'm very disappointed put it in
the review does not have a smell I'm
going to smart to this up so quickly
this really fits my room's aesthetic
what resumes so let's turn this on and
see what else is in the box oh I love
instructions oh this is actually
something that I do love here is a SIM
card injector one of the great things
about this is you can get an LTE plan so
you can basically have the internet
wherever you go which is very exciting
because I have a card right here will
allow me to have LTE access and we're
not quite there yet so don't let me lose
this that's what I get for being
reckless here's something you guys have
never seen me unboxing for Microsoft
Surface power cable oh are you asking me
questions she just sounds like someone
that would be my friend like she either
is a voice brand-new or somebody that
would just if you'd like to sit around
telling you with the duo that looked a
little microphone icon towards the
bottom of your screen
let's open up the surface pro X keyboard
before we get this all set up I'm so
excited to see this little stylus that
they have it's a new slim version it
just fits perfectly into the keyboard
which is such a great idea not only does
it fit nicely inside of the keyboard but
also charges there look at this oh yeah
oh now this this one has a smell it
smells a little bit like like a ziplock
bag or something baby you've ever
smelled a ziploc bag I think that's what
that sounds like
and here it is our little flying stylus
put you back in your home let's get this
connected Wow it's like magic and this
just folds right up just like that and
you can use it as a keyboard it's asking
me to insert a SIM card yes I will looks
like it is located somewhere in the back
here getting in a little mouse pad so
that I could be gentle with my new
friend let's get our ejector oh that was
nice if only it was that easy to get out
sim cards on phones and you go and
that's that connected I'm connected sim
card is in now we're just gonna finish
the set up and we'll continue on with
this video
this is the surface pro X it's the
latest two and one to join the surface
family and it has a starting price of
$9.99 has a new processor that was
co-developed between Microsoft and
Qualcomm it was based off their
Snapdragon HDX Microsoft claims that it
has three times the performance of a
MacBook Air including all-day battery
life of around 13 hours
it also has fast charge capabilities so
you can charge up to 80% in less than an
hour you can choose between 8 or 16 gigs
of RAM and storage options are 128 256
512 gigs
that's the surface all set up I have my
pen connected I've also got my xbox
elite controller connected because one
of the things that I do love about the
Microsoft Surface is I can also game on
it
now obviously you can't do crazy
processor intensive gaming for my sister
and I we tried playing SIA thieves on a
video in her channel and it worked out
really well and that was on the laptop
right now I'm downloading a few games to
test out one of things that I love so
much about Xbox and Microsoft is there's
a lot of games that you can also play on
Windows 10 and on Xbox so I'm
downloading a few games to test this out
but of course this is a touch screen and
I can doing some research about
illustrating now I myself am NOT an
illustrator I'm not an artist as you
have seen by some of my previous videos
of my drawing attempts have you seen
anything better didn't think so so I
have an incredible artist Cory basil who
has been in some of my videos previously
and doing drawing tests on the iPad I'm
going to challenge him to test out the
surface and see what he thinks as far as
drawing goes obviously the iPad has a
lot more apps available for drawing but
one of the cool things that I'm looking
forward to testing out is Adobe fresco
the dhobi fresco isn't available yet on
the surface but I'm looking forward to
checking that out because they said that
they are configuring it to work very
well with the surface so right now I'm
going to pass this off to Corey to do a
quick illustration and see what he
thinks about it so while he's drawing on
that I think that maybe Jen and I should
do another drawing challenge what do you
think do you think we should yeah yeah
all right jolly challenge
[Music]
I'm here with my mom professional
illustrator Jenna I on the side
technicals your time idol that's really
great
we're gonna be doing a non-dominant hand
drawing challenge so I loved him you
think that you're better at drawing left
hand I don't know so when I was unboxing
my surface I was like oh I don't know
I'm really bad at joining whatever and
then I just sort of writing with my left
hand and it was actually really really
good
Wow I was like did it take these surface
pro X or didn't take me 30 years to
realize that maybe I have some
left-handed talent that we haven't
tapped yet we can find that out today so
we're gonna do a obviously a drawing
challenge again this is gonna be so fun
I had so much fun the last time we did
this I wouldn't believe what trash I
wasn't drawing it can be shocking
maybe I'm right-handed no because I've
seen you draw before and you're oddly
like artistic I am garbage so I'm like
well it can't be any worse so why not
use the other hand and see what happens
okay okay so we're gonna have Tyler
who's behind the camera yes he's gonna
text us an animal you're gonna be
Chicago first do you wanna go first
should we need rock paper scissors for
it okay okay you I will choose for you
to draw first
okay okay no cuz I definitely look a
cheater right now when we play uno keep
your cards but I certainly won't like
cards away from my eyes snake hi
wait that's an anaconda shark whale
dolphin tuna salmon wait a salmon Salman
ah I was even gonna like really get into
it and draw you know like the colors
this is the sockeye salmon
I love the sockeye say especially
specifically Alaskan sockeye say but
have you ever had it if you have it you
try out those reviews it's gonna raise
our false isomalt
robux is incredible we're gonna make a
bit thicker so I think that I have
guessed the fish okay it was incredible
I don't even get to draw like the gills
or like wait a minute why sockeye salmon
is it green they're red and green
the Pacific salmon I believe they're
more like the silvery color okay wait a
minute we need to look up what the
Alaskan sockeye looks like because I
didn't
oh okay didn't say Alaskan you did it
but I prefer they lost the question I do
know my way I do Wow there are a lot of
salman species do you see the red one
that I was trying yeah like Daniel I
didn't really get to the red yet I
normally just see the Salman on my plate
and yes I know it's pronounced salmon
but I think that's funny when people are
like a little but they've got a little
bit of green in them yeah that was a say
the sockeye he's got green this is an
erect penis ready to go okay well I was
not my best work I was trying to give
him a green face all right well I guess
it's my turn now okay
when you have the keyboard attached but
you have it like in this layout and you
go to type you can write and it'll
automatically just put it as text that's
cool see that and then it showed up
right here yeah hit fight for all he's
really fun for all all right well now
I'm gonna delete your masterpiece I'm
super sorry okay we're gonna do
something polar bear I didn't even
freaking do anything yet okay a tiger I
have not even stuck the stylus to the
it's a slim slim service pen but it's a
stylus a snail does this look like a
snail Tina
ha I mean let's know Gina all right
let's start over this monsters already
turn to you they don't know it I knew it
forgot okay like I'm drawing the same
exact thing that I just wrote doesn't
matter if you have to play put the rules
a sign do you know what it is does it
look like that is that a G yes orgy okay
so I guess you're not getting it um I'll
start over
they will know a guinea pig know they'll
know when they know I feel dumb no it's
okay
Panda yup there it was the Panda pixel
phone and then like what you said
alright let me just finish my drawing
now the pixel phone well because I
because why would not be a panda it's
the Panda color
I can't just on this mom totally a panda
it looks like a lemur you're so mean to
me panda melt
yeah the hairdryer he's getting melted
it's time to leave my YouTube channels
now later let me sign it it's not bad
you should have stopped with like just
the ears in the circle so this is weird
because I feel a extremely confident
with my right hand
alright gentle thank you so much for
hanging out with me here let's see what
Cory's been working on can't be anything
worse than this so I'm back here with
Cory he's been working on an
illustration here on the surface pro X
hello hey how are you I'm doing very
well Jenna and I were up here trying to
draw it obviously it's not something
that either one of us are good at but
Cory you're an illustrator a painter
you've actually painted this for me I
commissioned this okay more on that
later I'm working on a really fun office
tour video so stay tuned well we're
talking today about the surface pro x
obviously you just so much digital
illustration on your iPad so this is
this is all new for you yeah very first
time using this you handed it to me I
don't know three hours ago and said here
have at it never used the software never
used the pens or the surface and I gotta
say I'm pretty into it I didn't think I
would be I wanted to be but I didn't
think it was gonna happen that I would
be like dad's you know I'll stick to the
iPad but it was actually very exciting
because there are things that I really
like about this that are different from
the iPad I really like the pencil are we
calling this a pencil
I think I'm used to calling it a pencil
this is the newest one and I think
that's the style that I tried once on
the surface studio student circa see you
yeah and the thing of the bother he kind
of about this was this maneuvering tip
felt I'm not a big ball point an artist
I do from time to time but this felt
very ballpoint pen so then I do a lot of
work that's pastel and pencil oriented
and it just didn't feel right to me with
that bouncy I'm sure some artists do
prefer this this falls right in line
with the Apple pencil and that made the
transition a little bit smoother for me
I think then he's a hold style this is
interesting statistics by versus the old
style this is the old new style and this
is the new slim version so that is
interesting as it is a lot more like the
Apple pencil there isn't a racer on the
back of this which is pretty funny Apple
a lot of times I like to take a
screenshot mid process to either say for
posting later or just for reference so I
can jump back to it and trying to figure
out how to get a spring grab on this
since I've never used the surface before
I'm sorry I should have told you yeah
but I just double click this yeah and it
popped up that's cool another cool
feature one of the things that I found
out mid drawing that I thought was
really cool something that I didn't
think I'd ever care about the size is
different than the iPad pro and it's
really cool because it feels more
cinematic it feels more sixteen by nine
it also feels more old-school sketchbook
to me know I used to have the wire
sketchbooks I'll flip it and I'll hold
in my lap like this and draw and I found
myself doing that like I used to draw so
I would be tucked in like this drawing
and then I realize it was the size was
different and it's long enough to kind
of hit inside there anyway I drew a
panda bear and then there's like a fish
here does that have any reference to
something that Jenna and I tried to a
draw earlier I just heard something
about it and
there and a sockeye salmon and so
naturally my imagination took over and
thought what could I do with that this
still I felt I mean I handed you this
thing you've never even touched it
before never even heard of this app and
you managed to draw this look this is so
cool is that yoga mat yeah so the story
is he was on his way to yoga he was
doing so good he had his routine down
but he was sidetracked by a bowl full of
sockeye salmon I wasn't too familiar
with surface and what it has to offer
for artists did a small bit of research
but decided to just jump in on concepts
and give it a try so if you have any
recommendations for drawing apps
obviously I mean you can download these
same apps on any of the surface products
so what I'm interested in is if any of
you guys have ever used any drawing apps
because I don't know I really have no
idea and I think this was the one that a
few people had recommended yeah there's
anything else that you guys have tried
out let us know Jenna and I were just
using the Microsoft whiteboard that's
like built into it we also reusing paint
a little bit more work to do on this the
bowl is supposed to be full of fish
bones okay well you can work on the fish
and I will show you guys the completed
image right after this
I want to test out the gaming so I went
into the Microsoft Store and found one
of the top free games and it's called
asphalt a I personally have not played
it yet but in the description it said
350 million players can't be wrong and
then Tyler said we of course I've played
asphalt 8 I have not so this is gonna be
my first time I'm now 350 million plus
one but the best part is I can hook up
an Xbox controller I'm using the new
elite controller
I guess I'm driving now I'm the man
asphalt 8 player oh my god I'm
incredibly talented
the drift is so sick I've crashed my car
again oh my gosh am I gonna come in
first am I gonna pass up this idiot to
be a champion of asphalt 8 there's a
really good chance
did I hit them I did I'm so I'm so
apparently talented 350 million players
are absolutely not wrong I can't believe
how much fun I have happiness
hey I'm even more excited because I'm in
first place right now
look let's me you that's me not you
that's me never forget hope you guys
enjoyed this first look at the new
Microsoft Surface pro X so far I'm a
huge fan I absolutely love the new pen
style I love the fact that this thing is
super thin super light let me know what
you guys think in the comments below and
let me know if there's anything else you
guys would like me to check out here on
my channel and don't forget to subscribe
and I will see you guys in my next video
bye
[Music]